cinnamons quarter I used to steal
subscriptions when I was in high school
I might still be still less I'm
influenced by everything by life in
general from my dog having puppies to my
kids going to piano recitals I'm writing
make songs about just life this is like
a diary when I moved to Atlanta and
hooked up with Andre who formed the
group Outkast I was like match made in
heaven and here we are today 50 million
records left so I'm Hugh manna tearing
all the way around I care about people I
started the big Kids Foundation because
my whole motto is it's easier to mold
the young mind than it is to repair
broken just the b.i.g to be our big boy
aka daddy fat sacks and these are my ten
count them 10 essential things I need
are chillin roll let's go first
essential right now is the big boy
bandana not only is it a key souvenir to
the shoes for running tour but it's also
good when you're going inside the store
to go get some rolling papers and it's a
lot of people packed pull this [ __ ]
over your face like this and nobody
knows the shoe everybody want these
these are collectors items you got to
get these backstage from the kid himself
though these aren't jazz hands these are
exfoliating gloves and then you do it I
get circular motion small circle it
takes all the dead skin and brings a
nice nice glow until your skin so
exfoliate you can get these anywhere
tell them big boys section
[Music]
I have sex really good with socks on you
keep some warm socks on the keeps the
blood flowing through the genitals
that's why I chose getting two socks you
ever wonder you watch a porn on the man
got the socks on it's a secret at all
men who's slinging heavy pipe know if I
keep your feet warm keep the blood going
1.5 [ __ ] Hawking my daddy used to
smoke when I was little I thought they
said we couldn't say we I like the
purple lollipops the bird that's the
best card I got a medicinal card as well
my eyes got better it was a miracle not
got a coupe I can get another diagnosis
with it I think my leg I cannot that gal
rack in the front leg 1.5 nice it's
sensor it's a goose down comforter cuz
I'm nothing say night-night like a bed
full of duck as feathers it's good for
you back your throat your mind and your
body and soul it's like your mother's
want it on the case on the weekends i
throw rose petals in inside that [ __ ]
just to make me feel romantic
Zemo followed by Zippo and then again
this is it mother
mo it's like a phone within the phone
you get double life of the battery with
a motor on the road there's a lot of
phone calls interviews a lot of business
on my phone never goes dead so whenever
you need to get in contact with big if I
say my phone did I mean I want to talk
[Music]
I picked the Stillwater because it is
good at actually rejuvenating the organs
then just playing spring water or tap
water which I never drink tap water
because they're spraying so much [ __ ] in
the sky all that shit's getting in the
water
don't be drinking water at the same you
feel me bite you on stage performer you
losing a lot of minerals and vitamins
and things like that so this is
replenished bee pollen capsules with
granules you got to do it actually
boosts your immune system as well this
is a superfood try it
these are your friend yes sir daily dose
every day the Zee collard green ain't
good out on this road you eating a lot
of bad things and it's kind of hard to
get it like a home-cooked meal whatever
so sometimes I just give my mom cooking
that batch I can heat a [ __ ] up for
weeks on that in zip floss this is the
double floss technique yes if you got
some big-ass teeth flossing is good
after eating all the collard greens and
all the chicken that you want you don't
want to kiss about in the mouth and it
tastes like a soul food surprise
the promotes healthy gums and clean
shiny teeth you're watching GQ ten
essentials like this video comment below
subscribe follow us on Twitter using the
hashtag GQ ten
you